philippe petitcolin bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
février dernier les deux syndicats
avaient mis en demeure général elektriks
pour que les accords soient respectés ou
est-ce qu'on en est maintenant bien ce
jour aucune des contreparties
industrielles dans été réalisé à savoir
une taille critique 2275 salariés la
localisation en france des centres de
décision les axes du projet industriel
la mise en place d'une gps et et les
deux emplois promis dans la
diversification que en 2019 nous avions
trouvé un équilibre difficile entre deux
positions totalement opposé tout d'abord
général trick qui voulait faire un plan
licenciement justifié par une ps
imaginaire du marché d'autre part des
syndicats qui demandaient des garanties
industrielle aujourd'hui le pse est
passé gel des acquis sociaux est en
cours et aucune des contreparties
industrielles mais respecté par général
vous c'est l'enjeu la justice mais
quelle chance selon vous que votre
demande aboutisse bah écoutez ce sont
des accords de droit français est donc
légitimement general electric doit
rendre des comptes devant le juge pour
l'accord de 2019 signé avec lens en
amical et l'accord de 2014 et avec
l'état français
maintenant il ya en fait une demande un
jour fixe est à dire un procédure
accélérée
espérons que le juge va entendre cette
demande et si déficit pas si nous
n'arrivons pas à avoir gain de cause
il y aura de toute façon un procès au
fond mais qui sera beaucoup dans un
courrier bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie a reconnu des non conformités
aux accords de 2014 et 2019
est ce qu'une plainte de l'état peut
être envisagée pour appuyer votre cause
effectivement comme nous l'avons fait en
2019 si l'état n'agit pas suffisamment
en utilisant les moyens à sa disposition
notamment la loi pacte qui permet de
sanctionner hauteur du doubs
le montant de l'acquisition n'hésiterons
pas une seconde assigné l'état au
tribunal administratif afin qu'ils
défendent les intérêts de generali
l'intérêt des territoires industriels et
non ceux de mitaines à l'américaine qui
a donc dépassé notre filière stratégique
de l'énergie
et qu'est-ce qui explique general
electric ce n'est pas tenu ses
engagements est ce que c est la crise du
comique qui a cloué au sol le projet
industriel notamment en matière
aéronautique
est-ce que vous avez des retours de la
direction tout à fait en 2019 en a été
perturbée par le cos vise mais à la fin
de l'année ont vu un rattrapage des
commandes et aujourd'hui nous avons
beaucoup de charge d'ailleurs général
éthique continue délocalisé en inde par
manque de ressources tuto pse et 2022
devrait être l'année record depuis que
le site existe tous les indicateurs
financiers sont ouverts et c'est c'est
uniquement parce que general electric
n'a jamais eu l'intention de développer
et sitr en france et que sa stratégie
est basée sur le dumping fiscal et
social consiste à délocaliser dans les
pays à bas coûts elle de localiser les
centres de décision et les profits dans
les paradis fiscaux
quelle est la situation de l'emploi plus
généralement sur le territoire de
belfort où situez est ce que tout ce qui
se passe du côté de general electric
impact les belfortains quel est l'état
d'esprit environ bien se rendre compte
que pendant longtemps nous ayons deux
donneurs d'ordre alstom et général
electric qui faisait vivre tout le nord
franche comté
l'un a racheté l'autre et general
electric qui a racheté alstom devait
créer l'hymne et d'emploi et c'est tout
le contraire qui se passe
donc l'impact est terrible sur sur le
territoire en terme d'emploi 1500
emplois general electric supprimés
depuis les racheter autant de sous
traitants
le prix l'immobilier s'effondre les
impôts augmentent donc l'impact sur le
territoire est palpable
tous les jours avec des commerces qui
ferment des cadres qui déménage et donc
c'est vraiment la survie de ce site qui
compte encore trois mille emplois
trois mille emplois indispensables dans
la transition énergétique pour le
nucléaire pour l'hydrogène ou le
renouvelable
et donc c'est tout une une filière
stratégique pour la france que général
éthique en train de dépecer sans être
inquiété par personne dans ce qu'on nous
faisons aujourd'hui c'est ce que l'état
aurait dû faire depuis déjà bien
longtemps c'est saisir les tribunaux par
rapport à des accords de droit français
qui sont opposables ingénieur électrique
pour lequel il est sans le son qui
existe et maintenant il est vraiment que
de temps d'agir avant qu'il soit trop
tard le message est passé merci philippe
petitcolin d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
représentant cfe cgc de l'entité
turbines à gaz française de générac
général elektriks abel